five-month-old sadie hasn't had her
first step or
first tooth yet her parents have already
taken hundreds of photos
keen to capture every moment she hates
it but the pandemic they say has robbed
them of one of life's most
precious experiences as a family i'd
been in there for three days with no
sleep
and then i was kind of left on my own
after a c-section i couldn't sit up and
i'm suddenly responsible for another
life with absolutely no
no help throughout the pandemic the nhs
didn't allow
birth partners to be in the room until
mothers were four centimeters dilated
in christie's case that led to more
anxiety
as a new mum christie says it's left her
feeling sad
about the experiences of giving birth
it's a time that can be
frightening um it's a time when you know
somebody's in a lot of pain potentially
and things can change somebody might end
up needing
an emergency cesarean these are all
stressful life events but social support
can buffer life events with 1800 babies
born
every day during the pandemic thousands
of other parents would have faced
similar separations
all aimed at reducing the spread of
covid19
jordan and lucy's pregnancy ended in a
miscarriage
a difficult time to have been apart
throughout the course of
the time since finding out that we were
miscarrying the only thing that
had given me any sense of like
directional purpose was that i just
wanted to like be there with you
and i didn't want you to be on your own
so as soon as i realized that
you were going through that alone and i
couldn't do anything at all about it
it just kind of hit me very hard it kind
of might rock but like
um i was in the room by myself
for seven hours and
yeah it was just awful today the
government called on maternity centers
to try harder to get the balance right
i think it's vital that all local
hospital trusts and local health bodies
who have the
responsibility for administering the
rules in their particular
area really lean into this issue i would
like to see
more trusts get that balance right to
allow loved ones in particularly
when difficult and tough news has to be
delivered
the nhs told us while it is
understandable that the pandemic has
caused expectant mums
increased anxiety the important changes
to maternity services
backed by the royal college of midwives
were made to keep women
and their families safe now we have
moved past the peak of the pandemic and
after extensive engagement with the
various professional bodies involved
new guidance has been issued to all
maternity units
so partners can attend antenatal and
postnatal clinics safely
in addition to attending labour which
they have been able to do
throughout the pandemic so this week
maternity services can start to find
ways to reintroduce partners
under these new guidelines baby steps
towards getting delivery suites
back to normal sadia chowdhury sky news